the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome people I'm glad to see you this
afternoon we finally make our transition
to sound film I hope that you endured
the silent era with good spirits I think
you'll find as the semester goes on that
even some of the silent films you found
less compelling when you began will
resonate for you and become more
valuable and my expectation is that some
of you will decide after the fact that
Keaton and Chaplin and perhaps even for
some of you Murnau presented you with
films that were at least as memorable as
the most memorable sound films but we
now move into a segment of the course in
which every object has more than merely
artefactual value although the
artefactual value of these remarkable
films is very great and as I indicated
earlier in the semester my hope is to
toggle back and forth in some ways in
each of our conversations about these
films on the on our syllabus to toggle
back and forth between what we might
think of as an aesthetic perspective
talking about the qualities in these
texts that make them artful memorable
long lasting worth worth something even
beyond the eras in which they were
created on the one side and then on the
other side more an anthropological kind
of perspective rather than an aesthetic
one what do these texts tell us about
the culture from which they come in what
ways do the social and moral and
political mythologies of the society
find a complex articulation in these
texts so those are the two sort of
perspectives between which we we
oscillate we now turn to the kind of
film that emerges after the advent of
sound in 1927 and we can say that the
period roughly between 1927 1928 when
when the first sound films began to be
made and the era in into the 1950s after
the briefly after the advent of
television is that era is often thought
of as the often called by some film
historians the Golden Age of Hollywood
and it was in some respects maybe in
many respects our golden age it was
certainly a golden age in terms of the
size and loyalty of the audience for
American movies and I'll come back to
that in a moment and what happened of
course in this up in the sound era was
that an industry emerged a more neutral
term for the Golden Age of Hollywood
might just be the studio era because
what happened in the sound era was a
fortification and extension of the
system that had already emerged and
which we've discussed and which David
Cooke catalogs very fully in the
required reading a fortification and
extension of the system that had emerged
in the silent era the mass production
system that was already in place in the
silent era was perfected and extended
the principle of the specialization of
labor became even more complex and
effectively deployed in the production
of motion pictures and in this period
about in the period between 1928 and
1930 for example Hollywood spend what
was then a tremendous amount of money
500 million dollars in gearing up for a
translate the transition to sound it was
almost as if silent films became
obsolete almost instantly almost
instantly and the famous line from from
the what's the title of the first sound
film the jazz singer who's the star the
theater singer Al Jolson right and and
there's a famous and there isn't very
much dialogue in that film oh there are
some eight interpolated songs there's
very little synchronous dialogue but
there is a little and one of the lots
most famous lines I maybe the most
famous lines in the film of line in the
film comes at a certain point where
someone says you you you ain't heard
nothing yet and the implication is you
ain't seen nothing yet either and and
and it is certainly the case that within
three years they were there were no
sound films really being made some of
the cut as I've suggested earlier a
comic and and still illuminating
perspective on this process of Hollywood
adjusting
to the advent of the new technology of
sound is dramatized for us in the
wonderful musical we're going to see in
a few weeks
singing in the rain so at in this era
then after the advent of sound the
movies become America's dominant
entertainment form and in the period
between 1930 and 1945 7500 films are
made by the Hollywood production system
approximately almost exactly in fact 500
films a year think about the confidence
that these that these that this
production system needed to have in in
its capacity to get a return on the
amount of on the number of films that it
turned out and think about what it meant
that the entire society was now geared
toward this mass form of entertainment
we can get some measure of the
tremendous popularity of the movies the
centrality that the movies assumed by
the end of the silent era and into the
sound era if we think of some numbers in
1938 for example that what we might
think of as the central height the apex
of the of the studio system of the sort
of the sound era there were a total of
80 million admissions per week in the
American movies that comes to something
like 67 percent of the population now
I'm sure some people were going to the
movies more than once a week so it is it
literally as if 70% of the population
was attending the movies every week but
it's something close to that
far more than half the population had an
intimate weekly habitual relationship to
the movies and the form that the
Hollywood system took on was surely in
part a reflection of this increasingly
intimate and knowledgeable connection
between a mass audience and the kinds of
movies the kinds of stories that
Hollywood was was was pumping out can
you think for example why the exactly
the broad attributes of the system that
I've already described can you think
about why those broad attributes would
encourage the development of what we
would call a system based on stars in
which movie stars the names of
particular actresses and actresses
become so well known that that their
name
carry the film and people go to the
movies to see Gable or Colbert or
whatever famous performer famous
activate and there were dozens of such
films and in a in a tearing system in
which there were great stars at the top
be level stars below them sea level
actors and actresses below them and the
the border between those were somewhat
permeable there was a kind and and an
extraordinary number of people in the
society were familiar what not only with
these these these stars and the
particular films they had made and would
follow them from film to film but we're
also familiar with what was a partly
mythological and fictional story about
their private lives that the Hollywood
publicity system kept pumping out about
the stars and performers and what was
essentially created was a kind of
mythological system in which the stars
were literally for the audience
characters who were creatures who were
literally larger than life and something
some vestigial form of that star system
still survives today in the great
celebrity stars rock stars and some of
the great movie stars of today but it's
on a very different scale and the number
of such recognizable figures is much
smaller today than it was in the heyday
of the Hollywood era or when there were
dozens and dozens of actors and
actresses whose whose entire careers
were known intimately by the audience
and whose work from film to film was
something that particular members of the
audience would follow religiously would
follow as if they were members of a kind
of fan club um so and then the second
aspect of the star system was coupled to
it and linked to it was what we might
call a genre system
what's a genre a category or a kind of
story
so the elegy is a poetic genre and the
Western is a narrative genre and as soon
as we mention Western or elegy or
situation comedy to talk about a
dominant television genre as soon as we
say that a set of expectations
immediately enters our mind right we
know that there are certain features
that westerns have we immediately know
when we hear the word Western what
historical ear of the story is set in we
know what the customs will be like we
can predict what kinds of an
were likely to see in the film we can
even if we know the western genre well
we can even predict pretty pretty
accurately what kind of story were
likely to be told and and and and what
the rhythms or trajectory of that story
might be not because we know the
particular Western but because we know
the category and every Western that
calls itself a Western is in some sense
in conversation with every previous
Western what we're talking about here in
part is a new form of literacy or at
least not exactly a new form but a
central form of literacy a form of
literacy that emerges in popular art
when a mass audience becomes more and
more knowledgeable about the conventions
and operations and formulas on which the
system depends and by the middle by the
by the middle of the 1930s virtually the
whole history of the silent era and all
the new genres that were elaborating and
and fulfilling themselves in the sound
era were now intimately known by
segments if not the entire American
American audience so to come back to my
question why would a system that
emphasized the repetition of stars and
the repetition of genres across
experiences be a particularly
appropriate or useful one for the kind
of system I've described what's the
answer if it's a mass production system
why would what the alternative would be
for it to clarify my question why would
we not have a system in which every
movie was a unique experience did not
make gestures toward a whole class of
other stories to which it belongs in
which it wants the audience to compare
it or that a series of stars would
emerge so that every time you see a
Clark Gable movie or a clue that
Claudette Colbert nor we or a Barbara
Stanwyck movie you associate those
Harper those performances in those films
with all the earlier performances in
which you see why is that system work
what's the answer all right you know if
that's right in any way because it
because it's familiar you know what to
expect it's a branding you know that and
in fact if you think about it if you
want people to shell out money every
single week you can understand why the
notion that they should be getting
something familiar might work for might
might be important it's possible that
you could get people to spend
of a significant amount of money or at
least a small amount of money in the
early days admissions were not that
expensive four four four one experience
but if you expect them to do it week
after week after week it's very it's
natural that you would expect that you
that that that the system that would
develop would offer the audience certain
familiar landmarks um and what in other
words the answer and I think it's a very
good answer
the answer is that a mass production
system lends itself to principles of
repetition and economies of scale what's
an obvious thing if you if you're a
studio and you're making a lot of
westerns what's the how can you save
money do you have to do you have to hire
the horses every time maybe you have
your own stable right not only that
maybe if you have a scene of a stampede
you can use it in more than one movie
you don't have to film it again right
and in fact a lot of early westerns have
stock footage that were put in from the
they would film a tremendously exciting
cattle stampede and they would use it in
four or five different movies that
needed stampedes right the same with the
sets they don't have to tear down the
western town and rebuild it for every
movie right so in other words what the
one could say that there are economic
insight incentives that encouraged this
system but this is another example of
that magnificent paradox that I spoke to
you about earlier in the term the
paradox that the crassest of alliances
between Commerce and Technology should
be the enabling conditions of a
narrative art why because even though
the origins of these input of these
strategies may very well have been
totally commercial as they begin to
elaborate themselves they inevitably
become more complex the audiences begin
to generate expectations the people who
are repeating themselves begin to repeat
themselves with variation they even if
they never intended to get better they
would get better and of course some of
them have are excellent professionals
and they do want to do a better and
better job right so that what happens is
the system begins to refine itself even
if it begins in the crassest of
intentions figure out a way to save
money and make as much money as we can
by giving the audience the same thing
again and if the audience would buy the
same story over and over again no doubt
Hollywood would give it to them but of
course they have to introduce variations
just to make a living right just to make
people come back
then as they as these variations begin
to elaborate themselves something
complex and rich begins to begins to
emerge and this knowledge that the
audience has becomes what we might call
a form of literacy a form of popular
literacy so this much more one could say
about this and I'm being I'm being very
abrupt and and and and overly brief
about the way this system elaborated so
suffice it to say that there emerged in
this in this era a series of
recognizable separate categories of
moviemaking westerns gangster films us
certain various various forms of comedy
various forms of social realism certain
forms of historical spectacle right and
and and other sums your smaller genres
like the newspaper picture right which
is a kind of smaller sub-genre of we're
gonna see one example of that tonight
and so that what I'm trying to do over
the next couple of weeks and especially
in this week is trying to demonstrate
these principles in small by talking
today especially about certain aspects
of screwball comedy and by placing that
particular Central Hollywood genre in
the larger context of this manufacturing
system this mythological system that
we've been that we've been describing
one way of explaining what I've been
what I'm trying to get at when I talk
about these stars and genres and the
purely commercial origins of what
becomes a rich set of narrative
expectations is to say that I'm trying
that I'm what I'm really implicitly
dealing with is a problem it will seem
less of a problem to your generation
than it did to generations earlier but
it took a long time before the American
American society began to recognize that
the movies were a signature art form of
the amount of American society and that
if American society was going to be
remembered for its artistic achievements
in the 20th century the movies were
going to be one of the prime instances
of its artistic identity as a society it
took a long time for Americans to
recognize this in fact the Europeans
recognized it before the Americans did
and one of the fundamental reasons for
that is that our ideas about what our
is were in inherited notions that came
essentially from traditions of
romanticism and modernism which laid
tremendous emphasis on pure originality
on the idea that the work of art has to
be Sooey generous unique to itself that
has to grow out only of the individual
genius of the artist right well this
notion of art is actually a very
time-bound one it's not really a
universal notion of art at all
the notion of art that I want to suggest
you is a more populist one it goes back
to Homer and to the various forms
various forms of epic performance and
this notion of art is a more communal
one in which the artist is a singer or a
speaker to the main parts of the
community to the whole of the community
or to a large part of the community and
in order to do that kind of singing to
do that kind of address the the singer
the poet the storyteller needs to use
the categories and the story forms and
the language that is that that that is
known by the majority of the community
right and and in this kind the aesthetic
for this kind of art is an aesthetic of
familiarity in which in which meaning
and significance is generated not by the
shock of but by a shock of total
recognition of what every are everything
in the text being new or innovative but
by something else by the fact that
certain very familiar strategies are
suddenly very very slightly and it's the
slight variation from the familiar that
generates the significance and what I
and I'm going to try to demonstrate
these principles in fact all of the
clips and films that you're going to see
over the next few weeks and especially
in in today's viewing and lectures are
embodiments or instances of this
principle as I hope as I hope you will
see what we're talking about here to
borrow a phrase from the film scholar
Leo Brody
whose essay an aesthetics of connection
is required reading in the course we
might say that what we're trying to
identify here is an aesthetics is an
aesthetics of connection in which the
links and connections amongst different
texts or amongst different performances
are emphasized in which the familiar is
a central element in artistic experience
most people love to wreck
nice the familiar it is not the case
that art always must continually
surprise you in fact art that is
constantly surprising that makes no
assumptions that you can share or that
better or that go back to someone that
that allude to or refer to earlier forms
of the of the experience probably such a
text would doesn't even exist there have
to be even if the allusion or reference
to ancestors is one of antagonism in
which the text is saying look how
different I am from my ancestors it
still needs its ancestors in some way so
that the the notion that a text can be
entirely creatively original is itself a
kind of modernist and romantic fallacy
in any case the artistic principles on
which the Hollywood film is based are
artistic principles we could identify as
populist or democratic
Democritus right and they're based on
the idea that the familiar and the
everyday can be transmuted into
something more complex by good
performances by good writing by by by
the creation of a compelling story and
that meaning is created not by a single
unique creative act but by a but
essentially by a conversation and
communal process in which a particular
perception or sense of the world is
juxtaposed against older instances of
the same thing and by comparison one
learned something about where one is in
the particular new text an aesthetic of
connection it's one measure of the
complexity and social centrality of the
movies in the 1930s 40s and early 50s
that we can find in the system three
separate kinds of comedy it's a measure
of its maturity right not just one but
three fairly robust separate strains of
comedy and this even excludes musical
comedy the musical film which could be
said to be a even yet a fourth strain
not just one form then but but three and
the one the form of comedy we're
focusing on today is screwball comedy
but I want to say a word about the other
two strains to give you at least some
sense of where work where we're coming
from the first significant strain that I
that I want of would would like to
mention to you is is
what I call anarchic comedy it mobilizes
something that's elemental an elemental
impulse in many comedies and in maybe in
the comic impulse itself that at some
very deep level which is an impulse
toward an Arctic destruction there's
always a hidden in comedy at least the
kind of skepticism or suspicion or
hostility toward the established and the
respectable and one form that that can
take in in in in in comedies is a kind
of systematic anarchy in which in which
the larger respected the large respected
structures of a culture are
systematically or sometimes unsystematic
aliy disabled or dismembered and over
and over again in the comedies of the
Marx Brothers something like this
happens I won't I won't mention titles
but but there are a number a number of
tile I think I mentioned one a few last
week or the week before a Night at the
Opera in which which concludes with the
entire set of the Opera falling apart
breaking down and that kind of
destructive there's a there's another
film that thing that the Marx Brothers
made in which the in which they are on a
football team and we see one of the
things that Groucho does in that film is
he wrote he gets the ball and he runs
the wrong way and he scores a touchdown
for the other team but then he keeps
running and he starts running out of the
stadium I mean there was a sense that
what what the rules of this game are
silly let's ignore them and and so this
this sense of the dissolution of
boundaries and the anarchic chaos that
follows from the breaking down of of
established categories and edifices is
part of the pleasure of the these Marx
Brothers comedy and even extends in some
way to a kind of deconstructive attitude
toward language itself and many times
the dialogue in a Marx Brothers film
will sort of go nowhere it will they
will end up making no sense in others so
even language itself is reduced to a
kind of anarchic nonsense that times in
the Marx Brothers films you know you can
get another an even crueler version of
this would be in the Three Stooges
right The Three Stooges are a version of
this kind of anarchic comedy and
there's a final version I should mention
a rather distinguished one in its own
way they films by the actor that
associated with the actor WC Fields a
gravelly voice comedian who often
portrayed people who were half drunk and
were very hostile toward children it was
very anti sentimental he would kick
children or spit at them but act as if
actually have children were were
smelling annoying things who should get
out of his way so he could keep drinking
his scotch that sort of thing so there
was a both an anarchic and a kind of
subversive element to this kind of
comedy a second strain of comedy even
more powerful and artistically more
valuable very very interesting one which
continues to be influential films are
films films from this tradition have
been remade recently in American in
American cinema we and this is the
strain of comedy we would call worldly
and that other scholars have called it
it's not mine not my label and one thing
that the label intends to acknowledge is
that many of these directors in this
tradition where Europeans and they
brought a much European attitude
especially towards sexuality they were
they were much more amused than shocked
by sexual shenanigans
so one measure of the worldly comedy was
it had a more generous and a less a less
puritanical attitude toward infidelity
toward good body itself towards sexual
allusion and sexual bye play right they
still were not explicit by today's
standards you didn't see nudity in these
films but they were more open about the
fact that men and women actually engage
in that behavior and even sometimes take
pleasure in it an acknowledgment that
was more difficult for mate for non
worldly films to make and the central
director in this tradition although
there were others was Ernst Lubitsch I
put his name up on the board there his
dates are 1892 to 1947 and he made a
series of films especially in the 30s
through the early 40s that are still
regarded as classics of this kind of
worldly comedy trouble in paradise
designed for living a film called
ninotchka in 1939 a film called
to be or not to be in 1942 an immensely
bold film in which Jack
the comedian plays an actor who who
impersonates Hitler then filled the film
is set in Berlin and he actually plays
as a double of a double of Hitler a very
a very bold film on a on a par and
intellectually I think and artistically
an even more powerful film that then
Chaplin's the Great Dictator although in
the same in it shares the same ambition
and these worldly comedies are often
told infidelity stories or stories that
a story's as I've suggested that took a
much more benign and amused attitude
toward our tour toward our sexual crimes
and misdemeanors and these are both
these strains of comedy are robust and
deeply popular in the era but the form
of comedy that I want us to focus on and
that I mean that that we're centering on
for in in the in this week it is the
most important of these of these strains
of comedy it's what what has come to be
called screwball comedy and let me say a
few things about screwball comedy as a
category describe it a little bit and
then I want to show you two clips that
are intended to illustrate many of the
principles on trying to articulate here
and we'll come back to this idea of star
and genre in these clips as well because
they'll they're that those elements are
also at issue or embedded in what I want
you to look at maybe I should have
mentioned if you were curious about the
later incarnations of of worldly comedy
I meant to mention that for example in
1998 Nora Ephron made a film called
you've got male how many of you have
seen it at least a couple that's a
remake of one of Lubitsch's films and in
fact the the Lubitsch film a shop around
the corner is a much more wonderful film
and it's a it's a measure I think in
part of the power and authority of
Lubitsch's imagination and the elegance
of his comedies that they continue to
inspire imitation in that way
what screwball comedy is is in some ways
a distinct
of a signature form of American movies
it's a unique creation of Hollywood in
the Depression years it's derived in
part from Broadway forces of the 1920s
and also from the slapstick physical
comedy of the silent era it's a kind of
marriage or hybrid and remember we've
already said this but let me remind you
one measure of amateur media more of a
medium that's coming into maturity an
expressive medium a communications
medium yeah one measure of its maturity
or of its emerging maturity is that
forms that used to be thought to be
separate marry become hybridized right
so that you get and one of the things I
was suggesting about Chaplin's work is
it suggests some new maturity in the
film in the in this in the cinema as an
institution because it's marrying comedy
and melodrama
because Chaplin brings seriousness into
comedy he slows it down it's not merely
just slapstick anymore it's also
psychologically resonant it also can it
not only can it make you laugh it can
move you right and how that that
marriage or hybridization of two
essentially separate forms right
melodrama comedy makes for a richer film
and that's we say I'm what I'm saying
the same kind of thing about this
particular form of comedy this this
merging of ancestor forms of the
slapstick comedy of the silent era and
of course the slapstick comedy of the
silent era has its ancestors in in
staged slapstick and fast dialogue and
witty repartee that was especially
characteristic of a series of broadway
of forces made in nineteen teens and
nineteen and 1920s but but but the
particular historical moment in which
this form emerges is also a shaping
factor in the kind of comedy that that
and the subject matter of these comedies
the key qualities of screwball comedy
were a kind of irreverent humor a kind
of you know something of the anarchic
subversive skepticism that's
characteristic of many comic
perspectives coupled with very
fast-paced vernacular dialogue one way
to think about screwball comedy is to
say it's one of the first forms along
with along with singing movies movies
that have singing
I don't want to call them musicals yet
because sometimes they weren't fully
musicals or the musicals do emerge and a
very early time but any movie that had
singing in it like some westerns early
westerns had singing it could why
because sound had just come in and it
was a novelty right well one the
screwball comedy is one of the forms
that exploits sound in a really
expressive and powerful way compelling
way because it's full of dialogue and
it's full of really rapid rapid dialogue
most often arguments or conflicts or
quarrels between men and women
dramatizing certain kinds of conflicts
of gender in the in the in the course of
the film so key qualities irreverent
humor a kind of vernacular fast-paced
dialogue a fast physical pace as well
full of slapstick right physical slam
so a physical quick pace and a verbal
quick pace that are often in in in a
competition with each other to see which
can be more irreverent and quick and
fast and abrupt eccentric off often high
born characters who are made fun of and
mocked a lot of screwball comedy deals
with the upper social orders but they're
seen as clownish or foolish in some way
and in many school ball comedies the
wealthy characters need to be rescued by
their servants there it's a it's a very
modest form of class warfare in which
were in which there's in which in again
it's them remember it's the American
capitalist system is making these
stories so we're not going to have a
Marxist comedy that cuz that says that
says that the government should be
overthrown by violence right but what
the comedy right it's constrained in
certain ways the what what what the what
the story is able to say what the films
are able to say this is a manner to
which I'll return tonight and talk a
little bit more fully about the alright
the ideological and political limits
that are imposed on the Hollywood system
because it has to appeal to everyone and
I think what I have to say will clarify
this these questions in ways that you'll
find very helpful but for now let's
stick with situate with with screwball
comedy itself these high born characters
then they're criticized and seen as
clownish but they never seen as morally
evil in the way that a Marxist or a
social historian might might
might might regard them often the
stories are often in very deeply
improbable ones that are set among the
irresponsible wealthy irresponsibly
wealthy people often the aristocrats are
very spoiled and hard drinking in one of
the most famous of these a film made in
1937 titled my Man Godfrey directed by
Gregory LaCava
Carole Lombard and William Powell two of
the central situation of a screwball
comedy performers are other stars and
there is a scene in a shantytown by
there by the river in which the poor are
are located and the film seems to make
some sort of an acknowledgment of the
fact that the poor are here it's
acknowledging the horrors of the
depression but it solves the horrors of
the depression in the end by having the
wealthy people build a nightclub out on
the river banks to create employment for
all the unemployed and it's a kind of
very imposed and rather foolish in some
sense happy ending so the film
acknowledges in some that film
acknowledges more fully than some
screwball comedies the actual existence
of shanty towns in places where homeless
people are people who have to live under
canvas live many screwball comedies
didn't even go that far but it solves
the social problem in a in a
characteristically mythological and
magical socially incredible way another
aspect of these of these films is that
they for grounded women and this is a
very important aspect of this is partly
a function of the fact that in the 1920s
the the era of the flappers a new kind
of sexually liberated woman begins to
appear right some some of that is an
outgrowth of the fact that during this
during the First World War when so many
American men were over in were in
uniform right when women got new jobs
and were able to work get into the
workforce for the first time and that
created moments of freedom for women
that had never existed in American
society before and some of that is
reflected in screwball comedy and the
other films as well but especially in
the school ball comedies of the era
so at foregrounds women and it shows
women who often should have a great deal
more energy and freedom than the females
and other films of the of the era that
very often in these films Martin
marriage is seen for the first time as a
partnership of equals and as you'll see
in it happened one night that's the
ideal of marriage that's dramatized in
that film one of the two screwball
comedies we'll be looking at this
evening so there's the these films also
reflected the social disorientation of
the 30s the uncertain values that were
represented in the during the during the
Depression that the fear in some sense
that the culture was breaking down or
that the fabric of society was tearing
in some ways right and so these films
were ironically he was simultaneously
escapist because they were screwball
comedies and they did Saini things and
they they often had ridiculous or
improbable plots and improbable
characters and yet at the same time the
anxiety that they also dramatize the
anxiety of things falling apart of the
center not holding of of a kind of
danger to the to the established
structures and belief systems of the
society underlay even the even even the
most apparently escapist of these films
so there's a subtext then of strong
women of quarreling and manipulating
manipulative men and especially and of
course one of the things this dramatized
for us were were intelligent and witty
women like Katharine Hepburn and
bringing up baby or or Claudette Colbert
in the film you're going to see tonight
It Happened One Night or Rosalind
Russell in the second true ball comedy
you're going to see tonight his girl
Friday so in plant and then finally
their implicit then and what I've been
saying is that there are implicit in
these stories sometimes rising to the
surface sometimes just beneath the
surface but there as a kind of hint or
anxiety or what we might call first some
form of class conflict some sense that
the class structure of the United States
is a problem that the depression is
causing difficulties right and
in a form of sexual warfare in which the
inequality between men and women and the
unequal relations that men and women
have in the society are put in question
are quarreled with armed in some sense
even mocked and in many of these films
the actresses the dominant figure and
the male character is the secondary
figure and even and in some of the films
where the male characters are even more
powerful the best one can say is that
they're equals and that in itself
regardless of what the plot does was in
some sense it's not exactly
revolutionary but transformative
potentially transformative well what I
want to do in the time I have left to
show you two clips and they're intended
to dramatize many of the principles I've
been talking about so let me rehearse
them very quickly together I'm going to
show you two clips from us from from two
separate screwball comedies one directed
by Preston Sturges
in 1941 called the lady Eve a second
directed by Howard Hawks the director of
the second film we're going to see
tonight ball of fire Hawks is probably
of all the directors the one most
identified with screwball comedy
although as you'll see tonight when I
talk a bit more about him he was a
master of other genres as well but the
reason I want you to look at these two
clips as two is it multiple I have
multiple reasons right and uh it's the
multiplicity principle and criticism
because what I want I want you to
recognize as you're looking at this is
first the power of the star system
because here's Barbara Stanwyck at this
point in her career she's one of the
dominant female stars of the of the of
us in the society I'm one of the biggest
moneymakers in the society and here we
see her in two films belong that are in
the same genre two different versions of
screwball comedy look as you're watching
well think about the way in which the
persona that she established the kind of
character she stood for in film to film
is both stable but also changing that is
to say the pleasure you take in watching
the two different versions of Stanwyck
is an embodiment of the principle I was
talking before talking about before when
I said that we need an aesthetic of
connection we need to recognize that
it's the familiar rather than the
completely strange and new that can
generate profound
complex a sense of artistic achievement
because because the the the Stanwyck we
see in these two films is in many ways a
radically different character but we can
also see certain continuities across our
character and we can take pleasure both
in what in what is the same about her
but even more we could take pleasure in
the variations she's working on this
persona so one of the things I that is
embedded here is a notion of acting that
emerges in the in the in the in the
studio era that establishes American
acting as something different from from
the classical British theory of what an
actor is the classical British theory of
what an actor is is that the actor
submerges herself in her role and and
becomes indistinguishable from the role
and that you shouldn't even be able to
recognize the actor from role to role
the American system that emerges from
the from Hollywood and from movies is an
opposite one in which yours not only are
you supposed to recognize the actor
you're supposed to take pleasure in the
way the actor not it's not really
Barbara Stanwyck but the characters of
Stanwyck plays the persona Stanwyck
established it in film after film after
film how does that persona evolve change
in nuances when when that persona is
presented with different sets of
questions different sense a problem and
what you can feel and this isn't just
true of the actresses of course it's
even true of the male stars who had more
freedom in there were more roles
available to them so people who were
interested in Clark Gable or in Humphrey
Bogart could watch him across watch
these actors across a range of films
each time not getting the same
experience but watching a variation on
the persona that the actor was setting
up so a new idea of acting a different
conception of what an actor's job might
be and of how the audience might you
know have a kind of literacy in
performance that would enhance and
complicate their sense of any individual
performance emerges in this era as well
and the Stanwyck Clips demonstrate that
the second thing I want you to see again
same principle having to do with with
screwball comedy itself here are two
different screwball comedies look at the
differences in tone they belong to the
same genre we can feel how much they
belong to the same category but also how
much variation there is
between them so the point is it isn't a
simple form of repetition at all it's a
form of very complex elaboration and
complication in which the relation
between one text in the category and
another text is far more complex
artistically satisfying and rich than we
might imagine if we described this
system in too abstract away so here's
the first scene from the lady Eve and
let me set the scene in this scene
Barbara Stanwyck plays a con lady she's
on a ship loaded with a rich wealthy
aristocrats wealthy American businessmen
and she and her partner are trying to go
them out of money right and she's
sitting at dinner trying to pick out a
guy that she was going to become her
mark played by the great American comic
and and serious actor Henry Fonda
he's very wealthy everybody knows he's
very wealthy as a beer he's the son of a
beer magnate an ale magnate and he's
sitting down in the dining hall of this
cruise ship and all the all the fortune
hunting women who are there wanting to
marry rich men are stealing
not good enough
what'd you say I said they're not good
enough for every Jane in the room was
giving in the thermometer and he feels
they're just a waste of time
he's returning to his book he's deeply
immersed in it he sees no one except
watch his head turn when that kid goes
boy won't do you any good there he's a
bookworm but swing him anyway how about
this one how would you like that hanging
on your Christmas tree oh you wouldn't
what is your weakness brother so Stan we
can combine our you see how what
intelligence shows what not we look over
to your left bookworm there's a girl
pining for you a little further just
further wasn't that worth looking for
see those nice store teeth all beaming
at you while she recognizes you she's up
she's down she can't make up her mind
she's up again I hope you see how we're
looking at this crude manual training
school within Louisville oh you're not
well you certainly look exactly like him
it's certainly a remarkable resemblance
you know I couldn't ask me to sit down I
suppose you're not going to ask when I
sit down I'm very sorry I certainly hope
I haven't caused you any embarrassment
so and so one of my ties on straight I
certainly upset them don't I now who
else is after me
ah the lady champion wrestler wouldn't
she make a houseful well you don't like
her either
what are you gonna do about it oh you
just can't stand it anymore you're
leaving these women don't give you a
moment's peace do they well go ahead go
sulk in your cabin go soak your head and
see if I care
why don't you look where you're going
why don't I look sure you're not the
heel I'm certainly sorry you didn't you
just take me right down to my cabin for
another pair of slippers Oh certainly I
guess it's the least I can do by the way
my name is pike Oh everybody knows that
nobody's talking about anything else is
my father Colonel Harrington my name is
gene it's really a genius come on okay I
hope you recognize which that was
embedded in that dialogue that was a
little too low what is revealed about
that character dramatized about that
character in that opening scene tells us
almost everything we need to know about
her not everything but almost everything
and you can feel the energy the wit and
of course who's in control of that scene
not the man but the woman now let's look
at another scene from from Howard Hawks
film ball of fire the basic situation is
Gary Cooper the man in the middle here
this fellow Gary Gary Cooper is the head
of a consortium of scholars who are
compiling a Dictionary of the English
language with special emphasis on
colloquial or slang English right and
and earlier in the film Gary Cooper went
to a nightclub and he saw the Barbara
Stanwyck character who's actually the
the mistress of a mob boss do a song and
dance number and then he spoke to her
interviewed her and he became very
excited by what she represented by the
by the by the linguistic resources the
verbal realities of American language of
the American language that he'd been
oblivious to and he wants her to
contribute to his project she's not
interested and she when she shows up at
the at at this at the lair of the man of
the scholars when she invades the the
nest of scholars she does it because she
although you don't know that from seeing
this clip viewers of the film would know
it because she's really on the run she's
afraid that her that her boyfriend the
mob boss is gonna bump her off so she
needs to hide out and that's really why
she's come here all right
so here is this scene from ball of fire
if I missed anything no I was just about
to explain you see the word pus means
face yes as for instance sourpuss
picklepuss sugarpuss implies a certain
sweetness in her apparel sure never mind
the etymology wish that I don't know I
didn't notice oh but her vocabulary even
an ordinary conversation you spoke to
them well yes in her dressing room a
dressing room yes unfortunately she she
disclaimed any interest in our project
in word so bizarre they made my mouth
water shoving your clutch for instance
hide some parts could you tell us what
was it like backstage silly viciously
illegible and perhaps ballerinas
giggling up and down I am staircases
possibly wearing tights I hope you're
picking up the subtext of these well
it's getting a bit late gentlemen
perhaps we had better get to bed
someday I'll tell you my experience
did you know huh I stood in the snow for
hours together is that a doorbell
but it's 1225 Oh must be the statistics
on San Salvador saltpeter did anyone
pick up on the joke there what why is
there a joke in a reference to saltpeter
it's used in the army to keep men from
getting too horny it damps down your
sexual energies and he's writing an
article about saltpeter okay I don't
know what scholar came up with this
brilliant description but some but but
there's a kind of convention now among
among Capra fans and peep and fans of
this movie to refer to this scene as The
Snow White and Seven Dwarfs scene your
coming here was the last thing I
expected well I do I said to myself Who
am I to get science the brush and I take
it you've reconsidered yeah that's a big
idea
would you that was Professor oddly
anymore hammer on oh hey who decorated
this place the mug that shot Lincoln
this is our workroom Oh your living
quarters are upstairs we that's a lot of
books all of them different I trust
uh-huh may I have your coat yeah thanks
Oh Greek philosophy I got a sound like
this with a radio inside are you sure
you don't want your coat well how do we
start professor you see this is the
first time anybody moved in on my brain
yep you've got some kind of a machine an
x-ray or vacuum cleaner maybe that's
what's out the words you want what's
your method professor well it's quite
simple if you'll be here tomorrow
morning not later than 9:30 tomorrow
morning oh yes I've arranged a
roundtable discussion with a few people
of various backgrounds aha you were you
don't think we could sort of begin the
beginning right now nearly one o'clock
miss oh let's get ourselves a couple of
drinks like the fire maybe and you can
start working on me right away I
wouldn't think of imposing upon you at
this hour
listen I figured I'm working all night
any hasty random discussion would be of
no scientific value you see I have to
have my notes thoroughly prepared for
the seminar tomorrow okay where do I
sleep I don't know where do you live
when Riverside but I'm going to sleep
here yeah well you don't understand mrs.
Shay we're all bachelors with the
exception of the professor oddly who is
a widower why no woman ever even Miss
Bragg who takes care of our needs goes
home every night at 7:30 if you want me
tomorrow morning at 9:30 but even the
most free thinking people must respect
the all right Phelan come on feel that
foot Oh Kate it's Ebell what do you say
it's cold it's cold and it's wet no come
here
closer closer oh come on give hello kids
look down my throat come on look I don't
know what it's like rosing this slight
rosiness it's as red as the Daily Worker
and justice or the Daily Worker Ritter's
The Daily Worker did you get that no The
Daily Worker is a communist newspaper so
when she says it's red as the Daily
Worker she's making a rather witty joke
especially for a gunman's mall let it
creep up on me I'll get to know them
come here physiology for all I know I've
got a fever field
it's specimen certainly and he wants to
throw me out of my tin Oh there'll be no
9:30 for me if you let me go out in the
rain no naturally not with the streets
cold and the subway hot and full of
germs
oh-ho I'm a pushover for streptococcus
can I have this now kid we'll call you a
heated taxi and furnish you with woolen
socks and warm slippers Oh chance think
of your article Potts see they get the
point
if I might venture a suggestion why
couldn't the young lady sleep in my room
professor P grill oh I can bunk in with
professor Robinson I sometimes do when
there's an electric storm
yes he's afraid of thunder Wow
well I guess I'll turn in my coat thank
you hi do fella
I'll show you to my room yes we are I
know a miss Thank You without any help
from I just rough out the directions top
of the stairs and the third on the left
this is all highly irregular what if
they should come to the attention of the
foundation and what about miss Prague
tomorrow what are you talking about this
is research isn't it yes certainly who
is that guy learned so much from
watching an apple drop Isaac Newton 1642
to 1720 second the law of gravity yeah
that's him and I want you to look at me
as another Apple professor parts just
another Apple
okay all right so you can get an idea
for how richly comic these these films
can be but also how rich the subtext the
sexual subtext can become even though of
course as you all should know if you've
been reading cook there was a production
code in force after 1934 and there were
all kinds of very elaborate rules
imposed on American movies a form of
self-censorship because the movies
feared censorship from the government so
they came up with their own system and
until sometime in the I guess it was the
1960s and the the the code held and it
had all kinds of ridiculous elements in
it one of the primary ones that people
always laugh about rightly I think is
that if it showed a woman on a bed at
least one of her feet had to be on the
floor but you couldn't show a woman
lying with both feet on the bed it was
too suggestive but you can see how
clever filmmakers and powerful
performers were able to make a mockery
of the of those kinds of constraints
because subtle and complex and and and
witty films are able to do many many
things that are in a suggestive way that
keep them from crossing the boundary set
up by the by the by the censors but
nonetheless have a powerful energy and
sexuality and so the the similarities
between those two scenes but also the
differences between them tell you
something about the way in which the
aesthetic of connection this aesthetic
of familiarity this popular aesthetic
operated in Hollywood movies
you